Everything you own from your clothes to
your car to your wife or your husband is
going to forget you and move on and be
replaced the moment you die. That's why
Allah says
you are busy with the world affairs
until you visit the grace. Brothers and
sisters, masid no way, the one that we
built is looking to another masid around
the area of Norway. Subhan Allah where
there's so many Muslims that do not have
somewhere to pray. This masid is only
$500,000 and any donation that you give
will go towards your because when you
enter that grave, nobody's going to
remember you except Allah. So make it
count brothers and sisters and believe
me if every single one of us give £110
£100 £1,000 that's going to be something
you will never regret on your makyama
and everything that you lose is going to
perish and go but your deeds and your
makayama are not donate to the link in
let's get to the video asalam alaikum
guys hope you guys are well inshallah I
want to get straight into this video as
you guys know uh a picture was released
of me and my wife and my two kids but
before I start I want to give glad
tidings to my wife I want to say may
Allah bless and preserve you because
like Allah says in the Quran yes when
they came out with slander against Aisha
and her Allah says don't think it is bad
for you rather it is good for you
because there's so many lessons that can
we can learn from the picture itself and
from the people that had actually
brought this to light to make it public
yes and for the person who took that
picture maliciously Allahh on the
inshallah we my wife and myself are
going to get all your good deeds
inshallah for that malicious intent and
if we don't have uh and if you don't
have any good deeds left you'll be
carrying our sins Allah subhanaa most
I have no problem. Alhamdulillah this
picture coming out. You know why?
Because firstly I want to address the
brothers because if we look at the
picture I think it's somewhere down here
alhamdulillah you guys can see just I
want you guys to imagine this guys. Yeah
this picture was to taken randomly. It
was not set up. It's not something I
organized to do etc to make myself look
good. Okay. This picture was taken
randomly. I think it was about maybe a
year ago. Yes. Cuz usually Saturday is
my family day. I love taking out my kids
and my wife out. And subhan Allah we was
out. And if you can see in the picture
guys I think it's on this side. Yeah.
Okay. You can see in the picture on my
left hand I have the pram which is my
daughter, young daughter, 2 years old.
Alhamdulillah. Yeah. On my right hand I
have my other daughter who I'm holding
her hand. And where is my wife? She's
walking casually besides me sipping her
hot chocolate that we got from HalfM.
Yes. Cuz I know she likes hot chocolate.
Now brothers, what do we learn from
this? To serve your family. And I want
to say alhamdulillah. Wall look how like
Allah says they plan and Allah plans and
Allah is the best of planners. Anytime
like the prophet wasallam said the one
who looks for his fault in his brother
or sister Allah will expose his own
fault in his house. Subhan Allah they
put a picture up thinking that it's
going to harm me or my family. Wai
firstly my wife's face is not. So you
didn't expose anything. Secondly, all
you've done is shown what kind of a
father and husband I am further not only
after my wife coming out but also the
picture in itself you can't orchestrate
that bro like it's not even AI genuinely
I am walking in public got my two kids
one pram one on my other hand while my
wife is walking besides me enjoying her
hot chocolate what does that say about
me and I don't want no praise every man
should serve his wife and his children
in this manner alhamdulillah okay
because sometimes and someone pointed
this out in a comment section. They
said, "Usually the woman are walking
behind dealing with the kids, run after
the kids while the man is doing his own
thing." Not with me. Alhamdulillah. So,
may Allah bless uh those who are coming
out and calling out these individuals
who Subhan Allah. The hatred they have
in their heart has come to the extent
where they are going for my my wife and
kids. Subhan Allah. And let me tell you
guys something and wall and I'm going to
show you how this is a slander against
my wife who's innocent of this and my
children my kids I swear from the rub of
the caba may Allah subhana wa ta'ala
destroy me and my family if what I'm
saying is a lie I'm taking a big oath
wall if my wife ever asked me to do a
single video when it came to that other
girl who rejects hadith please I would
like this question to be answered if
someone rejects hadith are they a
believer they are a disbeliever this is
anyone that says hadith is man-made is a
kafir. This is not something from me is
a kafir. That woman who is in her late
30s 40s who's not married and then we've
got this other sister which I'm going to
come to inshallah who is divorced had a
traumatic experience which I have full
information and I have pictures and I
will never stop to stupid to a level I
am never going to do a tit for tat. You
know why? Cuz Allah says in the Quran
repel evil with that which is good and
you see that the one you have enmity
with there will be friendship. And not
that I'm seeking anyone's friendship,
but I'm not going to stoop to that
level, but there is information that I
know. Wall, all I said to my wife is
when I was doing the video, listen, I
said I want to go through a content like
I genuinely find it cringy. Yeah. Okay.
And she's there talking about all sexual
stuff, etc. I said, can you go and just
see is there any picture of her without
makeup? Cuz she said, like I said, for
that matter, I don't know anything about
her. All I did is ask my wife. My wife
never asked me to do the video. And I
have no regrets doing the video.
Alhamdulillah. When it comes to the
other video of the other sister who is
trying to wreck homes, etc. with her.
Subhan Allah. My wife just said, "Look,
have you seen this sister?" She never if
she said to me, "Go and do the video."
So, what you've done is attacked and
slandered an innocent woman who never
ever said that. And you know why you've
done that? Because you know if you came
out and attacked her, looks you're
calling my wife, she's transgender,
she's your husband, she's ugly, she's
this. You are supposed to be about woman
empowerment. That's why I thank you guys
for showing your true colors. Wall Allah
works in miraculous ways. Allah says you
might hate something which is good for
you. You might love something which is
bad for you. So I want to say
alhamdulillah people are calling you
out. Alhamdulillah people are seeing
your reality and this is going to carry
on more. More people have been coming
out about the sugar daddy videos you've
been doing. Sisters are coming out
saying this is the red line.
Alhamdulillah I've never had anything
personal with you guys. It was purely
for the dean of Allah. You never like
the sister says I was minding my own
business. No you wasn't. You was calling
for wrecking houses and I know why. And
genuinely when I heard what actually
happened with you from a reliable
source, I'm genuinely sorry for what
your ex put you through which we're
going to come to in a minute. And then
you come and say which you had to
portray like this which is you're
getting death threats. Should I tell you
what death threats look like? Let me
tell this is what I'm in the studio.
This is a knife proof vest that I have
to wear when I go do dawa over layers of
layers and there are certain legal
sprays that we have on us. Not only
that, brother Saraj, may Allah bless
him. He's a security guard.
>> So I stopped doing security because of
the environment. So my brother asked me
he need security. So I come out of
retirement for my brother here.
>> Alhamdulillah. I was here at the D table
where someone got my back. So I do like
this.
>> I got your back brother. I got your
back. My back.
>> Our dowo tables. You know why? Cuz we've
had death threats. Active death threats
where police have come to my house and
said there's been an active death threat
on you and Muhammad. We have to let you
know. It's called an Osman warning.
Okay. That's what he call death threat.
So you're here saying that why would
anyone threaten you or dox you? You're a
single mother, so these lies don't work.
Sisters, please, genuinely, and I want
to thank you for exposing your reality.
You've dropped to a level where you talk
about woman empowerment, woman's looks,
all this kind of stuff. And
alhamdulillah, I have never insulted
anyone's natural look. Never. And even
then, that's what's wrong. And I
apologize for it. So, you are now
slandering my wife, insulting her, her
looks, whatever. It's glad tidings wah.
Allah subhana wa tala is the most you're
giving all your deeds. wall all the
people in the comment section and may
Allah bless so many people where
comments have been deleted coming out
and calling out the hypocrisy and I
salute you guys for that you know why
it's only a matter of time when you come
out with anger these two sisters who
have come out this doing this yeah when
you come out with anger and you have
animosity why because I spoke against a
huck saying don't cause for the
destruction of the house don't talk
about taking your baby and leaving not
all men are the same etc that's my only
crime so what I'm going to say is wah
you did not harm me one bit you did not
harm me or my life rather all you did is
rather prove I should be the father of
2025 with that picture subhan allah if
anything if there's anyone given a prize
I'm here I serve my household I serve my
my wife and my family and alhamdulillah
my wife is a living example and proof of
how I serve alhamdulillah so I'm not
trying to boast but if anything you have
just helped me so what I'm going to say
is this to the sister who is trying to
wreck homes because of a trauma that she
went through I know you've had two
failed marriages. And I'm just
mentioning this for a reason. I know
you've had two failed marriages and I
know you was married to a guy and
brother. Yes, I know. Okay. And I know
what he did to you. It will make every
single woman insecure, doubt herself.
And if this is true, from what I've been
heard from reliable source, someone that
knows you very, very well. Uh if I'm
going to say you're half Scottish, half
Libyan, etc. So what he done, may Allah
subhana wa ta'ala deal with him because
genuinely when I heard was like subhan
Allah. Sadly, brothers like this who
mistreat their wife because and you've
had two experiences which because and a
woman would never come out and
generalize all men except they have what
minimum two experiences with a man or a
woman who is for that matter to
generalize. No woman would have one say
failed marriage or whatever for that
matter and there's nothing wrong with
marriage that's halal to come out and
generalize everyone. So if you had two
failed marriages I'm not blaming you for
it. what your ex done I'm genuine sister
I'll be honest with you I don't want
this to be like I don't want to drop to
your level and start I've got pictures
of you and I've got this that I'm not
going to do that so all I'm going to say
is me Allah subhanaa tala heal you that
you become a woman who serves the um who
says I've I've went through that I've
been wronged and oppressed but I'm not
going to do the same and try to ruin
other people's marriages rather I've
healed and I'm going to serve the um
that women empower theirel and don't
marry that kind of men who don't serve
their wives who cheat on their wives And
I have to be careful with this because
this is again allegation. Okay. And I
don't know if this cheat means I had a
second wife or what. I don't know. I
don't know. I have to be careful because
it's another Muslim and I don't want to
fall into slander myself and wronging
and the stuff that I done. So much so
subhan Allah that I even heard he's a
dead beat father. Again, it's an
allegation which is absolutely wa I'll
be honest with you. If I had a child
from a previous marriage, I will make
sure I'm in her life every single week.
Wall not a single day missed. There are
deadbeat fathers out there and this is a
reality and men you guys are responsible
because of your attitude and you're not
man enough and don't treat your wives in
a correct way and you traumatize them
and there are also women who traumatize
their husbands. This spirals into people
having trauma coming out and trying to
vent it out on social media and then
that turns into subhan Allah what other
people being affected and all we're
saying is this wall there's nothing else
I can say again I want to thank those
who have made this picture public
alhamdulillah wall my wife facing and
you can't even see it properly subhan
Allah my wife doesn't have eyelashes on
she didn't even have lipstick on she
didn't have an eyeliner on she didn't
have um um lip liner or whatever you
want to call it your face okay if
generally she had foundation.
Alhamdulillah. So she's natural.
Alhamdulillah, she's naturally
beautiful. So the besides the beauty of
that image and how I am with my family
and besides, subhan Allah, how beautiful
I believe my wife looks. All I'm going
to say is for those people who are out
there attacking her looks, her
character, she's a man, she's a trans.
Wall, please carry on. I'll be honest
with you would say the people that
backbite me, I wish I can send them
gifts on your makyama. I that's the
place I need this the most. The
prophetam said, "If you knew the reward
of the people who've been through such
hardship and stayed firm, you would wish
that your flesh was ripped that you can
get the reward they get." So carry an
insult to my wife, bringing my family
into it. And the far right are actively
trying to track me down. I've heard
rumors, a brother came to me, he said,
"I heard the far right, one of them
saying that they are trying to put a
secret camera to where you live." Yes.
Alhamdulillah. And I moved location from
there. Alhamdulillah. If anything
happens to my wife because of this
image, the blood is on your hands. I'm
just saying this.
I have real death threats. If anything
happens to my wife's finger, the blood
is on your hands. And let me say it,
I will make dua against you day and
night. The only threat is that. Other
than that, you really see this picture.
Wall it brought no harm to me. If
anything, it makes me look good. It
makes me look like a good father.
Somebody commented said, "Is this meant
to make Ali look bad?" He shows what
kind of a husband and father he is.
Alhamdulillah. Allah will always the
truth like Allah says in the Quran when
truth comes falsehood perishes because
in his nature is bound to perish perish.
And guess what is anyone going to come
out? Those who are pro these people are
they going to come out and speak? They
would never cuz they are hypocrites.
They are never going to come out. And
let me tell you something. Subhan Allah.
I never Let me tell you something. I
said my my I said you cannot be the dust
underneath my wife's feet. I never
You're talking about AI pictures. What
are you talking about? We used an image
on uh um on YouTube. Hey, I never mocked
your looks. I never ever mocked your
looks. I mentioned your eyelash and
makeup. Yes. Which are both um not a
part of your looks. If if you can talk
about I never said about your eyes, your
this, your guys insult the way I look,
etc. This, my wife, etc. So,
alhamdulillah, Allah has made the matter
very clear. And wall, brothers and
sisters, as long as you speak to this
huck and speak the truth, Allah will
always come to your defense.
Alhamdulillah, the pictures that they
think exposes me and my wife, it only
makes us look better and we get the good
deeds and people are calling it out to
the evil that you're promoting and
pushing out by going for my wife and
children, a 2-year-old, a four-year-old
and a woman that's innocent all of this.
So, carry on doing the videos. All I'm
going to say is alhamdulillah
and Allah subhanahu wa ta'ala will
always expose the truth. That's all I
want to say inshallah. Please carry on
the slanders. Please carry on the
backbiting. We do need Abdullah in your
Makyama. And like I said to my wife
before in the video, glad tidings to
you. Alhamdulillah for all these deeds.
I'm actually jealous of you. I wish they
me as much as they did. Alhamdulillah.
Hey, we better cat.